back to when we're doing quadratic
theory okay so let's just take a
question like this
okay now because it's just am it's just
a quadratic
you could go ahead and you could find
using the quadratic formula
what the roots are but you can already
see thinking about the discriminant
right
the discriminant is b squared minus 4ac
b squared
minus 4ac okay so being that b squared
is just
4 and 4ac is going to be 28 okay
clearly the discriminant is going to be
negative which tells you that the roots
are
not real or complex however you want to
say it okay
so now that doesn't mean though that you
can't still work out what the um
what the roots and what the sum and
product of these are
okay because even though they might be
complex when you put them together in
different ways
you end up just having real numbers so
for instance what is the sum of roots in
this case
it's just minus b on a right
and in the same way you've got the
product being
seven that's all okay no problems now
you guys already know you can combine
these in all kinds of different ways for
instance
i might ask you to work out alpha
squared plus beta squared okay what
would that be equal to by the way what
what combination do we use
good so you take this to get the alpha
and the beta individually squared
but you end up having the two alpha beta
in the middle which is why you
compensate by doing
this okay you guys know how to do this
right but do you remember sometimes you
get a weird curveball
that might look like this um can you
work out what
hold on sorry here we go
can you work out what that's equal to
okay
now hold on here raise your hand who
recognizes this kind of question
yeah okay now now there's a there's an
insight to it obviously
it's in a different class of question to
all these other ones
because there's no beaters right so
there's there's no combination of these
that you can throw together
because you always have beaters in there
somewhere okay now who remembers what's
the what's the
trick right in order to get this out
does it remember
now remember remember right right i just
told you
that we're used to saying okay these are
your two building blocks right and you
have to build
every other combination from these two
okay
that's kind of a lie because they're not
the only two building blocks you've got
one
other piece of information in the
question namely
this guy okay now the question is what
does he have to do with anything
okay well remember what are alpha and
beta
alpha and beta are we we can say in
three ways right
um they are either roots
or zeros or solutions
right okay that's the way we talk about
these so what that means is alpha and
beta
if i put them into this equation okay
because they are solutions they should
solve the equation
should make the equation work right
so therefore as alpha
is a solution
to the original equation right i can say
alpha squared plus
two alpha plus seven is equal to zero
does that make sense
it satisfies the original equation so
does beta okay now what does this
have to do with this can you see it yeah
you see it
that that seven on alpha kind of gives
it away right i have to divide through
everything by
alpha which i can do because alpha is
not zero
south alpha sorry well is it this is
alpha plus beta but that doesn't tell
you what this value is
it does
so i say it again okay look i'm gonna
get it from here i'm gonna get it from
here okay
so i think this logic makes more sense
i'm going to divide everything through
general questions okay does that make
sense and the reason i can divide
through by alpha is because alpha is not
equal to zero why do i know by the way
the alpha's not zero
okay because of because of the the
coefficients here
and then of course what i want is just
these two guys so i kick the
minus two onto the other side okay so so
that's the answer
now why why did i bring this up i want
to draw
your attention back to this question
okay we were asked to work out this
okay now you can sure enough work out
the answer to this
by taking um alpha beta and gamma
and cubing all that right then you get
some rubbish at the end you have to
correct in much the way the same way we
did here okay
but how can we use this kind of fact
right the fact that alpha beta and gamma
are all solutions to the original
equation
how can we take advantage of that to
solve this question in a faster way or a
more elegant way
okay now i think we've already got
all these pieces of information right
alpha plus b the plus gamma i think it
was like three
yeah three is that remember alpha beta
um
b to gamma and alpha gamma is one and i
think the product is fine
yeah it's that right yeah okay so and
the original equation that we got them
from was what
x cubed well minus minus 3x
squared plus x minus five okay good
now therefore what i know is that since
alpha beta and gamma
just like alpha here they're all
solutions to this equation
right therefore i can say alpha cubed
minus three alpha squared plus alpha
minus five
that's zero it works beta cubed minus
three beta squared minus sorry
just one lot of beta that's also zero
and so is gamma
um okay sorry huge right
okay now can you can you see where i'm
headed and then you have to hold up and
then you remind us the things
you can take them all together yeah okay
now once i take them all together
tada there's the bit i'm after okay now
i still do have all this extra stuff
okay but the extra stuff
is stuff that i know about right um i
already know what alpha squared
beta squared gamma squared is because i
worked it out in
whichever earlier part it was okay and
obviously i know what alpha beta gamma
is because that was one of the first
results that i got
okay so i can say alpha cubed
beta cubed gamma cubed what's it equal
to
okay i'm just going to take all this
other stuff and put it on
the other side okay because once i add
all this that's all equal to zero so i
can just move it over
so i'm gonna get let's see three lots of
alpha squared
beta squared gamma squared again one lot
of the sum of the roots
so that's a minus yeah thank you and
then i'm going to get 15.
okay and i think you can take it from
there okay now
which way is better um when you cube it
all out
i don't know i think you you end up
getting a similar number of lines okay
however i think it's probably less error
prone
and more elegant and more thoughtful to
actually do it this way
especially since you've got these
results already that's okay
any questions does that make sense yeah
how did you get the execute
minus three expressions that's the
question
that's the original equation so i'm
comparing this
kind of like to this so it's kind of
like the um it's the sneaky
piece of the puzzle that you we always
ignore because we're focused on these
two
or focused on these three and you forget
that that's there and it's actually
really useful